well not long to go now so Russia synag
faces sakir starmer and prime minister's
questions we have uh rmps ready to
discuss what what may come up in the
comments uh with me for the
conservatives in a couple of moments
she's just coming in Rachel McLean MP
for Redditch but in the studio at the
moment for labor we have Nick Thomas
Simmons Shadow Secretary of State for
international trade and for the live
Dems we have Alistair Carmichael who is
the mp uh for home Affairs Justice
Northern Ireland but also the MP for
Albany and Shetland as well lovely to
see you both um uh Nick do you first of
all
um in terms of what's happening at the
moment strikes seem to be what a lot of
people are focused on today do you think
this is something that Kirsten will
pushed the Prime Minister on
well it's something that I think
certainly will come up in the duration
of prime minister's I haven't got any
specific Intelligence on on Kia's six
questions but of course I would expect
that to come up and I would expect the
government's failure to come up as well
I think the government has at best been
standing on the sidelines trying to
pretend it's nothing to do with them and
at worst has been aggravating the
situation by threatening highly
unnecessary and unwise new laws to
restrict the right to strike this is a
government that should be sitting down
getting people around the table trying
to hammer out a solution that's what we
need to see an active government doing
that Alistair do you think that those
who who are out today and potentially
will be out in the weeks coming up to
Christmas are Justified look I mean I
think the appointment strikes has to be
put in a proper context here and one of
the reasons why there is so much
industrial Conflict at the moment is the
cost of living crisis and you've seen
that you know coming to the Ford again
this week off chairman noticing that the
price cap is going to be rising again in
the new year you get food price
inflation this this week up 12.4 percent
so you know that is that's the the root
cause of the the discontent the
unhappiness that there is in in The
Wider workplace at the moment and you
know I think as you know the longer that
continues the more you see the um the
the inadequacies of of the support
that's been put in place the gaps that
that begin to appear and you know if
pmqs is doing its job today you should
see more discussion about that
well we have just been enjoyed by Rachel
McLean vote the conservatives thanks so
much for for coming in and we've just
been talking about strike action and
we've seen a number of picket lines
already today
um
what do you think the government should
be doing what do you think Russia should
be doing to get the country back to work
well I think obviously we do respect and
value all those Frontline workers we
know that they're working under pressure
and it is important that we get them
back to work because these are vital
services that people rely on whether
it's ambulances or whether it's
healthcare workers we do need them back
to work so look there is a lot of work
going on I know that the health
secretary is talking to the nurses for
example and I'm sure he'll be doing the
same with the ambulance drivers he's
having constructive discussions he'll be
continuing to do that because at the end
of the day our constituents expect those
services to be working you do value them
and of course we all went out during
covert and clap for these workers a lot
of people will say why on Earth don't
you just pay them more they are being
paid more so we have the government has
accepted all the recommendations of all
the pay bodies pay increases have gone
in across the board and that's the right
thing to do but I think we also need to
recognize that we can't
always accept every pay demand because
we do need to also bear in mind the
wider picture of inflation so we have to
have these pay settlements Guided by the
independent experts who look at the cost
of living pressures and look at the pay
scales across the board I mean if you
actually look at the nurses salaries I
mean of course there is a scale there so
they are pegged to a lot of indicators
to consider the pressures on nurses and
others it is right that we we make those
decisions and that we pay them what they
deserve but also we also have to be
responsible of course with the public
finances and inflation is the issue
that's going to actually erode those
workers salaries if we don't get it
under control and it's a fair point
isn't it that the government is using
these pay review bodies it is it is
taking independent advice about orders
being what these people should be paid
aren't they right to then stick to what
these bodies suggest it is an
ever-changing landscape loan it's
changing at a quite you know alarming a
speed at the moment and you know you see
people coming out in Australia you know
people getting picket lines and the rest
of it this has not just come out of a
clear blue sky you know these three
these sites have been there for weeks
and months and yes it's good that now
you've got the transport secretary the
health secretary talking to unions
whatever why on Earth was this not
happening months ago you know it seems
to me that it's always the case with
this government that yes they can they
can be relied upon to do the right thing
but only once they've tried everything
else first Nick Thomas Simmons for labor
will labor MPS be out on strikes on
picket lines supporting their
constituents the labor front bench will
be seeking to get into government which
is the best way that we can help working
people as the General Secretary of
Unison Christina mcanair has said very
clearly it isn't about Labor MPS on
picket lines it's about Labor MPS
getting into power to make a difference
for working people and what we're seeing
from the band the front bench from going
out we've decided collectively as a
shadow cabinet that that is our position
the position we are in at the moment I
doubt you could name a single Public
Service after 12 years of conservative
government there's in a better State now
than it was 12 years ago and that isn't
the fault of the workers the front line
workers who've given so much it's the
result of 12 Years of conservative
mismanagement and that now has been
exacerbated by the conservative mini
budget this Autumn we've got now this
economic crisis which is made in Downing
Street and working people up and down
the country are paying the price Rachel
in terms of that and I know you will say
oh there are global economic
consequences talk to what is going on
here we all know about the war in
Ukraine we all know about inflation
across the world but
um Nick is right isn't he that there is
a specific issue in the UK and it is
tied to that many budget that has made
life a lot worse for a lot of people
especially in terms of mortgage
repayments for example no I don't I
don't accept that Nick is right on this
that actually if I can sort of challenge
what he's just said
um we do have more doctors and nurses
working in the NHS since uh 2010 since
the last Labor government we've got
record levels of investment going into
our Frontline services and of course we
need to work with those who are
delivering the services including the
management the layers of management to
make sure that's well spent but look you
know I think everybody now serious
economic commentators including the
chair of the bank of England has been
very clear that yes we did see some
turbulence on the back of that mini
budget but these are not the structural
factors that are underlying the UK's
economic troubles and it's it's one
thing for you to say we've heard about
Ukraine but that is the reason why we
are seeing our economy struggling with
some of the headwinds that it is not
just Ukraine the aftershocks of covid
those Global Supply factors so although
perhaps you don't want to hear it it is
very important that we do recognize that
that is the root cause of some of those
problems that we need to continue
bearing down on those okay uh Rachel
Nick and Alistair uh both Nikolas are
shaking ahead as Rachel was speaking
there they can really not agree with you
but thank you all very much for coming
in and looking ahead to prime minister's
questions uh just also joined by our
political editor Beth Rigby who's coming
now talking about strikes Beth I mean we
don't know what kissed armor is going to
really push the Prime Minister on but
it's it is certainly very much the
flavor of what a lot of people are
talking about it is and I think that the
way I think this will go today is that
kirstan will want to press where he
thinks he's quite effective on what he
perceives to be Rishi sunax weakness
probably uh highlighting some of those
tensions on the back benches it seems
like calm Waters but there is still a
lot of unhappiness in the conservative
party about taxes going up in the Autumn
statement and there's these rebellions
Brewing on housing targets and wind
farms and I think for Rishi sunak's part
this will be an opportunity for him uh
to try and attack kierstama on what he
will say is not standing up to the union
so I think both men will have material
uh in this pmqs today to go at each
other and it has been this back and
forth on these two themes has been the
tenor of what happened last week as well
Beth Rigby uh Nick Thomas Evans for the
labor party Allah Michael for the lib
Dems and also Rachel McLean for the
conservatives thank you all so much for
joining us looking ahead to prime
minister's questions it's coming up
straight away after this short break
history Sean to increase uptake in women
and girls in stem education
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
news this live is the House of Commons
the prime minister is due to start prime
minister's questions at any moment while
waiting for him to take to his feet we
have our political editor Beth Rigby
here he's been in the job now what about
a month almost really settle into it
he's been in the job about a month and
uh he is settling into it but it's not
easy for him to get stuff done at the
moment Jane because what Rishi sunak is
facing is we're just talking about are
these rebellions on the back benches
around a number of policy areas uh so he
is uh in harness but I think that this
is something that kirstan will want to
lean in in on pmqs about this
characterization of Rishi sunak as a
weak uh prime minister and as I was
saying I think what Rishi Suna will want
to do is to try to take care starmer to
task over the unions given all of the
strike action and he will say I imagine
you call me me weak but you don't stand
up to unions I think this will be the
the tenor of this pmqs I think watch two
to see if
um if kirstma brings up issues around
tax raising because labor put out this
uh information today suggesting that a
windfall tax if it had been introduced
at the beginning of the year would have
raised by now 17 billion and I wonder if
he will also raise the issue of taxing
non-doms this is something he talked
about last week labor putting out the
view that that would raise 3.6 billion
pounds which they would then use to help
fund the NHS so there's a couple of
attack lines uh from Storm there on
sunak but as I said he will have uh
rebuttals in terms of Labor's links with
the unions and strike action let's take
the comments join me in congratulating
England on last night foreign
commending Wales for inspiring Millions
so wishing everyone a happy Saint
Andrews day
because this morning I had meetings with
ministerials in addition to my duties in
this house I shall have further such
meetings later today chubby Shepherd
to the Smith commission which promised
amongst other things that nothing in its
report would prevent Scotland becoming
an independent country should the people
of Scotland so choose can I ask the
Prime Minister does he share that view
and if he doesn't in light of last
week's supreme court judgment will he
bring forward legislation to allow that
choice to be exercised
well Mr Speaker we we did have that
conversation uh not so many years ago it
was described as a once in a generation
referendum but but I know we discussed
this last week I think what the people
of Scotland want is for us to be working
constructively together
to focus on their priorities that's
indeed what we're doing in his own area
investing hundreds of millions of pounds
in a growth deal and ensuring that with
a new concert hall we can enshrine
edinburgh's reputation as a city of
culture so Paul bearish foot
thank you Mr Speaker I've just returned
from the South Pacific and I found there
a deep
foreign
I've resisted the all black jokes Mr
Speaker but I found their deep concern
that the expanding tentacles of
communist China with my right honorable
friend agree with me that China is more
than Justice is put a systemic challenge
but in fact an expanding serious
geopolitical threat
prime minister Mr Speaker China is
indeed a country with fundamentally
different values to ours and an
authoritarian leadership intent on
reshaping the international order but
actions speak louder than words and
that's why we passed the new National
Security and investment act just
recently we used that act to block the
sale of Newport wafer Fab and this week
with our announcement of size World C we
ensure that China's state-owned nuclear
energy corporation will no longer be a
part of the project this government
making sure that we protect our
country's security
it now comes the leader of the
opposition
thank you Mr Speaker may I join the
prime minister in saying well done
England and I hope we can say that next
week and the week after
commiserations to Wales so I'm sure
we'll be back in the World Cup
Tournament before too long
and of course Mr Speaker we Mark that
that tomorrow is World AIDS day
Mr Speaker Winchester college has a
Rowing Club a Rifle Club an extensive
art collection they charge over 45
000 pounds a year in fees why did he
hand them nearly six million pounds of
taxpayers money this year in what is
leveling up secretary calls egregious
State support
[Music]
Minister Mr Speaker I'm pleased he wants
to talk about schools because we've
recently announced billions more funding
the most disadvantaged children catch up
with their lost learning
and we're driving up school standards Mr
Speaker but during covid during covid he
wanted to keep schools closed
we shouldn't be surprised because I
listened to parents and he listens to
his Union paymasters
Mr Speaker he's leveling up secretary
I'll see him down there who after all
was education secretary for four years
said you could scarcely find a better
way of ending burning injustices than
scrapping these hands out and here's
what he talks about driving up standards
just down the road in Southampton and
he'll know this
four in every 10 pupils fell their
English or math GCSE this year four and
ten is that six million pounds of
taxpayers money better spent on rifle
ranges in Winchester or driving
upstanders in Southampton
thank you
Mr well for me Mr Speaker he he talks
about school standards it's under
it's it's under a conservative
government and thanks to the reforms of
the former education secretary that now
almost 90 percent of schools are good
are outstanding
whenever whenever
attacked me about where I went to school
he is attacking the hard-working
aspiration of millions of people in this
country
he's attacking people like my parents Mr
Speaker this is the country that
believes in Opportunity not resentment
he
and that and that's why he's not fit to
lead
[Applause]
Mr Speaker
Mr Speaker
if he thinks the route to better
education in this country is tax breaks
for private schools in the hope they
might hand that sum that down to state
school that's laughable trickle-down
education is nonsense
a Mr Speaker it's not just the leveling
up secretary his education Minister
sitting there asks how much better would
it be if conservatives got rid of these
handouts he talks about his record it's
simple he can carry on being pushed
around by the lobbyists giving away 1.7
billion pounds to private schools every
year or we can put that money to good
use in the Tory Scandal he talks about
his record hundreds of thousands of
children leaving school without the
qualifications that they need I've made
my choice what's his
prime minister Mr Speaker we're
improving School standards for every
pupil in this country
for writing more good and outstanding
schools more investment in every single
school but he talks about choice this is
about supporting aspiration Mr Speaker
and that's what this government is proud
to do
Mr Speaker he really does need to get
out more
[Applause]
it talks about aspirations
Mr Speaker they are killing off
aspiration in this country and it's not
just education why is the dream of home
ownership far more remote now than it
was when his party came into Power 12
years ago
prime minister well Mr Speaker what have
we done in those 12 years the highest
the highest number of new homes started
in 15 years
largest largest number of first-time
buyers in 20 years
he took he talked about 10 years ago
what do we inherit the lowest level of
house building in a century
[Applause]
speaker
Mr Speaker the simple fact is this every
year the age at which people can buy
their first home goes up at this rate
under this government a child born in
the UK today wouldn't be able to buy
their first home until they're 45. now I
love my kids but I don't want to cooking
them dinner in 30 years time now Mr
Speaker
I I I've heard
I've heard
I've heard it my parties having a
relaunch apparently it's called
operation get tough
so so
how tough is he gonna get with his back
benches who are blocking the new homes
this country so badly needs
Mr Speaker we're delivering record
numbers of new homes under this
government that's what we're doing he he
talks he talks about toughness Mr
Speaker he's too weak to stop dozens of
his own MPS joining the picket lines
if he wants to support if he wants to
support those hard-working families and
show some leadership why doesn't he
confirm right now that no labor MPS are
going to join those picket lines
Mr Speaker whichever way you slice it
it's always the same whether it's
private schools oil Giants or those who
don't pay their taxes here every week he
hands out cash to those that don't need
it
every week he gets pushed around and
every week he gets weaker
but I can help him with this one he
doesn't need to do another grubby deal
if he wants to defeat that Amendment
from his anti-growth back benches on
National targets for housing labor will
lend him the votes to do so country
before party that's the labor way why
doesn't he try it
[Applause]
too weak to confirm no one on the picket
line but Mr Speaker it's the same old
labor ideas more debt more inflation
more strikes and more migration his two
he tells this party what they want to
hear I'll take the difficult decisions
for this country and that's the choice
Mr Speaker it's the politics of
yesterday with him or the future of the
country with me
thank you
speaker as hosts of this week's
International psvi Conference the UK
again highlighted the need for more
action to prevent sexual violence in
conflict with heart-rending accounts of
women in Ukraine being brutalized in
this way and reports that a third of
women in Conflict zones can be victims
will the Prime Minister Champion with me
as this special Envoy for freedom of
religion or belief the work being
undertaken with young people across the
world to prevent religion or belief
being weaponized which can later
manifest into sexual violence and
conflict prime minister because I'm
incredibly grateful to my honorable
friend for her dedicated work in this
area and she's absolutely right to
highlight that this week the UK hosted
for preventing sexual violence in
Conflict initiative conference it was an
incredible success I paid tribute to all
those involved and as she said we've
managed to reach a new political
declaration in the conference where over
50 different countries have agreed to
put an end to sexual violence in
conflict and she deserves praise for all
her work in this area literally the SMP
in Blackford yeah thank you Mr Speaker
I'm sure the whole house will want to
join me in sending prayers and
condolences to the wife of Dodie Weir
who sadly passed away at the weekend he
absolute giant of a man an inspirational
figure in Scottish rugby it's someone
who raised 8 million pounds for m d
Charities over the course of the last
six years our thoughts and prayers are
with Kathy with Hamish with Angus and
with Ben
Mr Speaker let me wish everyone a happy
Saint Andrew's day and those that know
anything about Saint Andrew know that
he's not just the patron of Scotland he
celebrated right across Europe that is
why it is such a sad sight to watch this
prime minister Ram through a bill that
would rip up 4 000 pieces of European
law laws that protect workers rights
food standards and Environmental
Protections
and it's an even worse sight watching
the leader of the labor party
desperately trying to outbrexit the
Prime Minister
[Applause]
style deal brexit is now the elephant in
the room that neither the Tories or
labor are willing to confront when will
the Prime Minister finally see reality
and admit that brexit is a significant
long-term cause of the UK economic
crisis
well Mr Speaker can I start by joining
my runnable friend in offering our
condolences to the family and friends of
Dolly Weir and I'd also like to pay
tribute to him for his campaign to raise
awareness of mnd which has made a big
difference Mr Speaker straightforwardly
I was proud to support brexit it was the
right thing for this country
it allow it allows
operation all of which Mr Speaker I know
the uh I I I noticed what he said and I
agree with him actually about the slight
dexterity of the either opposition on
these uh on these topics of free
movement and I know he'll join me in
reminding the leader of opposition about
his previous promise to defend free
movement of people not something that we
support Mr Speaker but we're also
seizing the economic opportunities
deregulating and signing trade deals
around the world that's how we'll drive
growth and prosperity
thank you Mr Speaker can I thank the
Prime Minister for his remarks on Dory
but once again what we're seeing over
brexit is better together we're used to
that in Scotland yeah the problem for
both the Prime Minister and the labor
leader is that when it comes to brexit
even their own voters don't agree with
them the last you gov poll showed a
record 56 now believe it was wrong to
leave the European Union and that figure
is 71 in Scotland one in five who
actually voted for brexit have now
changed their minds more and more people
across these islands are wise to the
fact that make brexit work is just
another stupid slogan yeah that Scotland
can't be stuck with the new brexit
together Coalition of the Tories and
labor so unless and Andrew is there can
the Prime Minister finally tell people
in Scotland the Democratic path to
escape Westminster control to deliver
Independence so we can get back to the
European Union
Mr Speaker he talks he talks about
democracy and votes I think the
difference between him and I is that I
respect the result of referenders
he talks about this it's just remember
one thing Mr Speaker we had the fastest
vaccine rollout in the world we had that
because of our freedoms after leaving
the European Union
thank you Mr Speaker Mr Speaker
manufacturing remains a key part of the
UK economy and for the West Midlands
that means Automotive that's important
in my constituency of rugby which
includes firms in the supply chain and
workers at Jaguar Land Rover with the
move to all Newcastle in the UK to
become electric by 2030 means that which
is critical for us to have a site for
battery manufacture assembly is already
taking place elsewhere in the world
where batteries are made so will the
Prime Minister give you support to the
bid for a gigafactory in Coventry
prime minister if I pay tribute to my
honorable friends efforts to progress
this project we're fully committed Mr
Speaker to securing investment to grow
our electric vehicle supply chain now
although he'll know I can't comment on
individual commercial negotiations we
did announce in the net zero strategy
350 million pounds of funding in the
automotive transformation fund to
support the development of that supply
chain and I wish him every success in
his bid Columbus was yesterday BBC
Northern Ireland announced cuts to
programming and jobs at BBC Radio foil
that in my view will leave the station
totally unsustainable the BBC Charter
places an obligation on that
organization to allow audiences to fully
engage on local issues this decision in
my view is a very clear breach of that
obligation leaving license fee pairs
outside the greater Belfast area without
proper local programming will the Prime
Minister act to defend this very
important local Public Broadcasting
Service prime minister Mr Speaker I
believe very strongly in local public
broadcasting and indeed the government
has taken steps to support local media
I'll be very happy to look at the
specific issue he raises and bring it up
with the BBC when I next see them Angela
Richards thank you Mr Speaker the people
of Guildford tell me they want women and
girls to feel safe and I'm delighted to
have had some successes in getting
lights turned back on including on
yorkies bridge on behalf of concerned
students at the University of study
Surrey does my right honorable friend
agree with me that even in difficult
times we cannot take a single step back
from the brilliant work this
conservative government is doing to
tackle violence against women and girls
prime minister Mr Speaker like my
honorable friend the government is
committed to tackling violence against
women and girls and making our streets
safer we've created the safer streets
fund which funds additional patrols
extra lighting and more CCTV and indeed
the street safe online tool allows users
including those in her constituency to
pinpoint locations where they feel
unsafe so that the local complete can
take appropriate action and I'll
continue to support her in her efforts
sorry yeah here thank you Mr Speaker the
two boys 16 year old boys Charlie fotolo
and Kiani sianko were tragically killed
in my constituency of irief and turns
made this weekend my heart goes out to
the families and friends left behind we
really need to come across the house to
address and Tackle serious youth
violence so can I ask the Prime Minister
what he is doing to address knife crime
epidemic prime minister
I uh I Thank The Honorable lady for her
question enjoying her and expressing my
condolences to the family and friends of
the two boys I also read about it it's
an awful tragedy and she rightly asked
what we are doing to make our streets
safer and Stamp Out the scourge of night
crime we're boosting the number of
police officers as she'll know 15 000 on
our way to 20 000 and we're also giving
them the powers they need to get knives
off our streets including lifting
restrictions on stop and search and
introducing new court orders to Target
known knife offenders I agree with her
this is something we need to do more on
and she should know that the government
will be fully committed to tackling it
Gordon Henderson thank you Mr Speaker
when will my right honorable friend's
government bring forward any emergency
legislation that's needed to deport
those migrants who came across the
channel illegally in small boats and are
now being put up in hotels playful by
hard pressed British taxpayers
prime minister well Mr Speaker we are
determined to do whatever it takes to
break the business model of people
Smugglers who are causing the needless
loss of life of people across the
channel and putting unsustainable
pressure on our Asylum system our
nationality and borders act opposed by
the party opposite Mr Speaker gives us
new powers which we fully intend to use
and we will take further measures as
required to properly control our borders
and reduce the number of illegal
Crossings
thank you Mr Speaker it was sad to see
in a video from his Oxford days the
future Prime Minister saying he hadn't a
single friend who was working class
and he's not likely to make any soon
because while he sits on a personal
Fortune he's refusing the reasonable
demands of nurses Railway workers and
many others forced to take industrial
action just Americans meet why doesn't
he give him the wage increase as they
need and fund it by making the rich pay
the same rate on unearned income as
workers have to pay for their hard graft
and whilst he's at it why not scrap the
non-dumb tax loophole that is all too
familiar with which is costing the
public
3.2 billion pounds
Mr Speaker I've nothing but admiration
and gratitude to our nurses for all the
work they do but
[Applause]
but unreasonable and unaffordable to
have a 19 pay rise now if that's what
the honorable gentleman thinks is I'm
sure the labor party can explain to us
how they would pay for that and the
impact it would have on inflation but I
tell you this Mr Speaker if he really
wants to support working people maybe he
should get off the picket line and end
the strikes
yes it might be
thank you Mr Speaker the train service
between wilmslow in my constituency and
London was always hourly direct and took
one hour 50. now you'd be very lucky if
you've got a direct train and the
journey time is double or often double
and that's not restricted to strike days
that's day in day out on Avanti trains
so can the Prime Minister tell my
constituents what the government's going
to do to sort this out and get the west
west coast servers back to what it used
to be because the service at the moment
is completely unacceptable
Mr Mr Speaker my honorable friend is
absolutely right about the unacceptable
deterioration in the quality of Avanti
service for transport secretary is
rightly monitoring and holding them to
account there is a plan to increase the
number of trains to 100 additional
drivers Mr Speaker and restoring the
full direct service between Manchester
in London but what this plan needs Mr
Speaker and I hope the party opposite
support it is Trade union cooperation
[Applause]
thank you Mr Speaker I'm I'm sure
members opposite felt a certain sense of
deja vu watching the Welsh defense
during last night's match after all they
know what it feels like to have Marcus
rashford run rings around them
[Applause]
Mr Speaker Mr Speaker Mr Speaker off the
pitch Marcus rashford has been a
tireless campaigner on child hunger so
uh in the face of fierce conservative
opposition yeah so will the Prime
Minister given that he delivered on the
pitch last night will the Prime Minister
give him the best thanks possible by
delivering free School meals for every
child living in poverty
Mr Speaker we're supporting almost 2
million children with free School meals
we also last year invested hundreds of
millions and pounds in the new holiday
activity and food program which in his
broadening that support through the
holidays for those kids who need it on
top of our work to roll out breakfast
clubs across the country Lake Drummond
thank you very much Mr Speaker the
pandemic has played Havoc with School
attendance and the children's
commissioner says that almost 115
000 children are now being home educated
at 34 uh it's 34 higher than before the
pandemic with little if any monitoring
of their educational welfare
even worse nine in ten local authorities
believe they have not been able to
identify home-educated children so when
will my right humble friend be bringing
forward the register of homeschool
children so they're identified and we
can be sure that their needs are looked
after and they're not falling through
the net prime minister Mr Speaker we
support the right of parents to home
educate their children and we know many
do well but however this is not the case
for all and that's why local authorities
must seek to identify those children
missing education we've published
guidance on the arrangements they should
be following and indeed make sure that
they have oversight of elective home
education that's the West thank you very
much Mr Speaker after record payouts
last year to shareholders the Royal Mail
recently this year announced huge half
year losses and plans to cut 10 000 jobs
while threatening the cherished
Universal service obligation which
guarantees a minimum six day a week
letter delivery service in the tradition
of the black Penny from 1840. why has
his government not yet committed to
investigate the mismanagement and
cack-handed mismanagement of this iconic
British service and protecting its
future and loyal postal workers
Mr Speaker again I have nothing but
gratitude and appreciation for the hard
work of our postal workers but when it
approach to go on strike especially
demanding pay as we have heard that is
simply unaffordable for hard-working
British taxpayers The Honorable lady
would do well to see that because in the
context that we're in it is simply not
possible to give people the type of pay
demands that they are making Andrew
Percy thank you Mr Speaker due to the
unique geography of Brigham goon and the
Isle of axon we are one of the most
flood-prone areas of the country so
whilst I welcome the record 5.4 billion
of food defense funding can I ask my ask
the Prime Minister ahead of next year's
budget to look at easing the rules
around how that money is spent so more
of it can be spent on maintenance which
is so important to keep in my
constituents dry
prime minister well Mr Mr Speaker I'm
very happy to look at that for my
honorable friend he's right to highlight
the doubling of the investment that this
government has put in flood defenses but
it's right that we get the mix right
between that and I'll take that away
with him Celine Fletch yeah yeah
thank you Mr Speaker the West Midlands
Chief Constable has revealed that a
vulnerable child was forced to spend two
days living in a police station during a
mental health crisis because the right
specialist help could not be found
I know more and more young people are
unable to access appropriate support for
mental health will he accept Labor's
plans to scrap private school charitable
States and use the money to fundamental
health professional in every school
Mr Speaker I'd say to the honor related
we've already committed to offer All
State schools a grant to train a senior
mental health lead by the end of this
Parliament already six out of ten of
doing so there's funding for all of them
to have it in addition to that we're
increasing the support that we give to
those with eating disorders because
she's right mental health does affect
young people this government is backing
those people to get the support that
they need
thank you Mr Speaker the number of
people crossing the channel is a
National Emergency the number of
migrants in hotels is a National
Emergency isn't it time we had a cobra
style committee involving the DWP D look
the home office and led by number 10 to
tackle this crisis
Mr Speaker I share honorable friends
frustration and I want to reassure him
that we will do whatever it takes to
reduce the number of illegal Crossings
to this country take any new powers that
we need to I look forward to working
with him to ensure we can do that
because this is fundamentally about our
sovereignty Mr Speaker and the proper
control of our borders whilst the labor
party have tried to oppose every measure
we have taken we will keep going because
we need to make sure that we stop the
crossings
thank you Mr Speaker last week the UK
government's regulatory policy committee
stated that the retained EU law bill is
not fit for purpose The Institute for
directors the TUC and countless others
have urged the government to scrap the
bill and businesses across Scotland have
already suffered severe economic damage
under this Tory brexit agenda and they
now see the outlet clouded with even
more complexity and uncertainty if the
prime minister is serious about
protecting the economy and looking after
smes why not do the right thing and
scrap this disastrous ideological bill
now yeah prime minister Mr Speaker
actually taking advantage of our
freedoms is going to drive growth in
jobs and prosperity in the United
Kingdom whether it's in late Life
Sciences whether it's reducing the
burdens on data for those smes whether
it's in the financial services industry
in Scotland that's how we're going to
create Prosperity across this nation Mr
Speaker and that's why we're going to
get on and deregulate post-brexit
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm gonna come again Mr Speaker my right
honorable friend and the chancellor have
rightly pointed out that leveling up is
for the whole of the United Kingdom and
as a Southampton man my right honorable
friend will know that since the 1970s
easily has been promised for much needed
chicken Hall Lane bypass so will he
agree to meet me and Hampshire County
Council to finally get this project
moving
well Mr Mr Speaker it's right that we
spread opportunity across the country
including in eastleigh and the South I
understand that it's for Hampshire
County Council to bring forward the
proposal for the bypass which I hope
they do at the next funding opportunity
and I'll ensure that my honorable friend
and the council have a meeting with the
transport Minister as soon as possible
final question
ideology is blocked to ensure wind
development Scotland for years peterhead
carbon capture clusters lost out funding
twice installing the classes are Reserve
pump storage Hydro schemes have been
blocked because UK government won't
discuss a pricing mechanism
actually does care about Net Zero and
cares about Scottish jobs will at least
take action to advance peterhead ccs and
pump storage Hydro in Scotland
Mr Speaker not only are we supporting in
this country carbon capture and storage
hydrogen offshore wind all new
technologies that will help us get to
Net Zero all of which will create jobs
in Scotland we're also supporting our
transition Mr Speaker and that's good
for the Scottish economy and it's good
for Scottish jobs and something the SNP
will do well to support that completes
prime minister's questions
well that was indeed prime minister's
questions we're going to have a little
chat with bethropia political editor in
a moment about what we heard there and
the exchanges but some breaking news
that happened during prime minister's
questions
Eurostar security staff have voted to
strike for four days in December overpay
now these are rmt members who are
working as security staff for Eurostar
they're going to walk out on the 16th
18th 22nd and 23rd of December so those
of course are
key days for those who will be thinking
about going away the weekend before and
the weekend of Christmas the workers
have rejected a pay offer they earn 10
pounds 66 an hour and they emphatically
voted for strike action with an 81 yes
vote now uh the rmt general secretary
Mig Lynch says uh he said these security
staff are essential to the urine of
Eurostar he says we don't want to
disrupt people's travels plans but our
members need a pay rise this is the
anyway management will listen he urges
Mighty who are the company that employ
these security staff and Eurostar to
come to a negotiated settlement with the
rmt as soon as possible so on top of
postal workers and train workers nurses
and ambulance workers we're now here in
the Eurostar security staff the latest
bunch of people to strike over the
Christmas period
well let's bring in our political editor
Beth Rigby who's here to talk about
provinces questions and Beth strikes did
come up in in prime minister's questions
but what Kirsten will really pushed the
Prime Minister on was uh funding for
private schools the amount of money that
could be generated if vat uh was removed
from them and of course targeting
Winchester which is the school that the
Prime Minister himself went to I mean
it's curious in a way Jane in that that
he went on that in that what what's the
issue for people on people's minds at
the moment it will be cost of living and
Strikes but what his starmer did there
is I think develop an attack line that
we are going to see again and again and
they've only gone up against each other
a few times but you can see what's
happening here uh Kia skarma raised a
policy issue this is VAT on private
school fees now labor have said that
they will in State uh put VAT on fees if
they win the election a clear policy
division between the conservatives and
the labor party uh labor think it would
raise about 1.7 billion but why did
kirstma or the manner in which he did
that was both in a personal attack on
the Prime Minister and an attempt to
sort of frame Rishi sanak again as
someone that he argues is weak I know
it's being pushed around by what labor
call invested interests and in this case
uh being pushed around or given money
unnecessarily in his view to those
private schools but he used it in a way
to remind us all that the Rishi sunak
went to a very very prestigious Public
School Winchester College because he
used it as tax breaks worth six million
that was the point kirstan was making to
Winchester college and he is trying to
frame the Prime Minister as someone who
protects vested interests instead of
standing up to working people but making
it a personal attack as well of his own
privilege and they have done this in
different ways raising the issue non-dom
status you remember Rishi sunat's wife
was a non-dom she has since changed her
tax status and last week people not care
starmer himself but labor politicians
raising the issue of whether or not uh
Rishi sunak has Private health care so
framing him if you like as a person of
privilege who is out of touch but also
trying to find these dividing lines
between labor and the conservatives be
it on the windfall tax labor talking
about how they would have introduced her
earlier how much that would have raised
or public schools now actually to be
fair to Rishi sooner he had a good
rebuttal on that in that he said my
parents worked very hard to pay those
fees his mother a pharmacist his father
a GP to pay those schools to fees to one
of the best public schools in the
country and he accused kirstma of
attacking aspiration attacking people's
aspirations
um the second line of attack was why why
don't you get tough with your back
benches on house building and he had the
rebuttal again Rishi sunak of well why
don't you kirst armor get tough on labor
MP's joining the picket lines but you
can see now the Contours of where kirst
armor clearly thinks he can attack Rishi
soon icon one is on privilege and the
second is on what he perceives as uh
Rishi sunak's weakness these are two
clear lines of attack that the labor
leader is now developing okay Beth
thanks very much for taking us through
that well let's return to the subject of
strikes and in the last few moments that
breaking news that Eurostar security
staff have announced strikes on the 16th
18th 22nd and 23rd of December and it
dispute overpay Olympian cues the Prime
Minister accused kistama of being in the
pocket of what he called his Union
paymasters and being weak for not
stopping labor MPS joining picket lines
he talks about toughness Mr Speaker he's
too weak to stop dozens of his own MPS
joining the picket lines
[Applause]
if he wants to support if he wants to
support those hard-working families and
show some leadership why doesn't he
confirm right now that no labor MPS are
going to join those picket lines
speaker which ever way you slice it it's
always the same whether it's private
schools oil Giants or those who don't
pay their taxes here every week he hands
out cash to those that don't need it
well I'm joined by some of those who are
on strike to discuss what they have
heard in the Commons Ian Taylor is a
postal worker he was on strike in
Manchester he's also the communication
Workers Union divisional office of North
Wales and the north west and Ewan
McGahey is a reader at the law school at
King's College London he's on strike
today as Branch President for the
University and college Union at Kings
very good to talk to you both thank you
very much for joining us in Taylor to
you first of all
um how hard would you say life is for
postal workers at the moment
extreme extremely difficult particularly
being on strike as well and it's against
the backdrop as you know of some very
difficult Economic Times and they are
under constant attack from the employer
at the moment so not only are they on
strike uh but they are feeling
particularly insecure at the moment
he'll say that that we need to adapt the
Postal Service things have changed
haven't they over the last few years
they've changed because of covert
they've changed because people are
becoming more Adept at buying things
online
um that the Postal Service does need to
change what would you say to those who
say that you're not being willing to
change with it
it's a falsehood it's an absolute
falsehood to suggest that uh we don't
want to change uh we we made agreements
with successful successively made
agreements with the company to change uh
we had a completely Fair uh agreement
about modernization it was called
Pathway to change actually uh that this
current leadership has walked away from
and anybody who knows Royal Mail will
see that it has changed significantly
and we're more than happy to change
what about Sunday deliveries you don't
seem very keen to do those
well I don't believe that's true uh I
think if there is a proper conversation
held about Sunday deliveries then
someday I think the Trade union fully
understands why Sunday deliveries would
be beneficial it's it's how we we
propose to implement all Sunday
deliveries
okay let's bring in
sorry and sorry I thought you finished
your point there let's bring in in you
and talking to us from from King's
College why why are you guys striking
today
oh great question so uh there have been
over 25 real terms pay cut since 2010
when this conservative government began
um so tuition fees for students have
been rising and Rising they've tripled
for home students they've doubled for
international students uh but all the
money is going not into their teaching
into teacher pay is being going into uh
buildings that are fancy and shiny but
not caring about the people inside it's
been going into big management pay
packets so pay cuts are the first thing
the second thing is the failure to end
the gender and raise pay gaps we've got
over 17 percent uh difference in average
pay between men and women in 2022 this
has got to end there should be equality
through fundamental reform to child care
and pay parental leave and the third big
thing is job security so many especially
younger early career researchers have to
apply for their jobs uh every year uh
it's one of the most insecure sure kinds
of workforces at the moment and
University could just be so much better
we need to have an end to the management
shutdown an end to management of
universities hoarding all the cash and
then to this government shutdown in
Failure to invest in public education
I mean you and what would you say to
those who would say that you know
because of the cost of living life is is
just harder for everybody at the moment
everybody is having to tighten their
belts
well University managements have had no
problem in raising international student
fees way above inflation as I say
they've more than doubled the
international student fees uh since 2010
and so there does need to be belt
tightening from management and people
sitting on piles of cash around
universities across the country but
fundamentally what we need to see is an
end to this failed privatized model of
higher education uh in the short term
what we need to do is have investment in
P the teachers pay by putting salaries
up in real terms and stop hoarding the
cash and putting into fancy buildings
and longer term we need to abolish
student tuition fees and talk about the
National Education Service for everybody
um and and also it's not just University
workers it's posties who are working
harder than ever before it's nurses uh
it's it's teachers that this government
has presided over the worst real terms
pay cut for the British public in modern
history their level of failure is
absolutely catastrophic and the sooner
that we've got shutter than the better
and in terms of the nuts and bolts dude
I'm not going to ask you what you're
paid but what would be the pay of an
average reader at somewhere like King's
College B
uh well look that's a great question and
I'm now much more of a senior academic
and so for me the reason why I'm out on
strike today is not just about my
circumstances but especially for all the
people who are going through early
careers and have incredibly insecure
jobs uh incredibly low pay so you have
many people who will be earning less
than the minimum wage people who are
doing incredible hours but because of
the way in which they're paid actually
they do more uh much more than uh
they're properly paid for
um so it's not just about my salary it's
about you you're yours personally of
course I'm just asking you generally
what what would be somebody in in the
kind of roles that you are doing you're
one of the people who are out striking
what would would that sort of normal
salary ban be
well to give you an example of a typical
graduate teaching assistant many of our
members will be on something like 20 000
pounds a year 15 000 pounds a year uh
particularly in London where I am it
becomes incredibly hard to afford the
rent uh The Soaring costs of energy
bills of course because the government
has failed to invest uh in renewable
energy and clean energy infrastructure
uh makes it incredibly hard uh and and
so you know University workers used to
be uh in a relatively secure and
well-paid job but like staff across the
country uh this has been getting worse
and worse since 2010. okay uh Ian
um do you think you have the public
support at the moment are you finding
when you're out on on picket lines that
the members of the public are coming up
to you and say they would like to see
their posties paid more
I I I think we've got a tremendous level
of support when you're out on picket
lines people are constantly pulling in
and expressing that support openly to to
post is you know the post is uh
delivered to 31 million addresses every
single day they are someone that the
members of the public know uh and Trust
so it is a uh most definitely uh
something we believe is going to be
important in this dispute going forward
and that is public opinion
and and what if what if the strikes
continue what if People's Christmas
posters is
affected people don't get the Christmas
cards people don't get those presents
that they've ordered online do you think
the public will still support you
I I see I think the public see the
bigger picture I think they see the the
attacks on Attack on on postal workers
um I I think they'll take it in the
round and what I would say is is postal
workers are also people who will be
affected they're customers too so I I
genuinely think the public will see the
bigger picture here and the the
unprecedented attack on postal workers
okay Ian Taylor and Ewan mccocky thank
you both very much for joining us